leave motivation 10 video and leave
nation hates Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so get ready to always follow
your passion disrupt the industry and do
what you love with Kimble musk and my
take on his top ten rules of success
enjoy
ok let's tick it off with rule number
one always follow your passion we have a
mutual friend of ours
Billy who has this phrase that doing
Estonia business from scratch is like
chewing gloss and looking into the abyss
it is really really hard and if you
don't like your glass sandwich you're
gonna have a miserable miserable life
and so it's a very important lesson do
it your passion right because no matter
what you do if it's making a difference
it's super hard to do it and so you
better enjoy
you better be passionate about it rule
number two disrupt the industry what do
you think is wrong with the way
Americans currently or in the past have
gotten their food the two different
paradigms in food today is industrial
food which is frankly food that doesn't
taste very good it's high-calorie
low-nutrient
and real food is a way to think about
food that is better for you and taste
better opportunity we have the challenge
we have in front of us is real food for
everyone and technology now enables it
to be delicious
there's certainly better tasting the
food is shipped across the country and
in a city like New York
once everything is shipped across the
country for most of the year and so we
came up with this idea to do into a
farming in the city and we're doing it
in Brooklyn
Tanner farms the same containers you see
on the back of ships we turn them into
an indoor farm the equivalent of a two
acre out to a farm in the heart of
Brooklyn rule number three do what you
love I started the kitchen and it was a
huge success but by measures of the
businesses that I'm part of
you know through my brother and other
companies there these are billion dollar
companies in a restaurant is a really
awesome very proud of the kitchen their
small business and I just kind of got
sucked back into Tekken so I joined a
few of the boards and I started a
software company and with some friends
and you know I just wasn't enjoying
myself wasn't that I didn't like it I
liked it but it's kind of you know if
you go from something you you love which
is food for me and you go to something
you like it's like chewing sawdust every
day that's just truly if you know what
you're missing you can't can't miss you
can't go you can't avoid it so I had a
very serious accident in 2010 I went
down a ski hill on an inner tube and I -
flipped and I landed on my head being 35
miles an hour I broke my neck and I was
paralyzed on my left
it was a Sunday without Valentine's Day
of 2010 Wow and on Tuesday evening and
they were rolling me into the operating
room and I just said you know if if if I
can walk tomorrow then then I'll just
cook some food and over the next morning
and I've never looked back rule number
four always be positive when SpaceX
started I think the first three rocket
launches weren't successful yeah and and
the fourth one was what would have
happened if the fourth one hadn't worked
we would have failed yeah but let's talk
about the one of the the failures were
spectacular I mean I would go out to the
island of Kwajalein with you know and
seeing giant exploding Rockets is quite
an amazing sight and I was one of the
only investors in SpaceX and I said you
know what if all I get to do is to see
these rockets explode well worth every
dime I put into this
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's something to be said of a
brotherly support but it was an amazing
thing to watch what he done would be had
built with those rockets at in I mean on
a shoestring in the middle of nowhere
and literally the middle of the Pacific
two thousand miles from Hawaii and that
experience we'd fly in these these what
are they called the if you really do is
you find the Huey's you feel like you're
right out of out of Apocalypse Now
flying to dr. Evil's island really
amazing I mean and again worth every
penny still to this day I'd say so I I
think the failures were actually
unbelievably exciting to be part of all
so if you want to have more self-love
check out my 254 series it's free the
link to join is in the description below
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself my ability
to only be comfortable in massive chaos
has been my biggest asset as an
entrepreneur like I would never take a
note like that scares the piss out of me
what these three people are doing right
now rule number five reach out to
interesting people what's the one thing
I recommend for first time entrepreneurs
when it comes to networking so one thing
I've done continue to do this to this
day is since I was 18 I would read the
newspaper that I read was a lie and I
find people who are doing something
interesting that I really care about and
by every government back in the early
90s I was picking up the phone and
calling them even seeing how easy it is
actually two people and about one out of
10 of them would say
Divini and out of that 80% of them would
not be that useful but the 20% every
polite as mentors and friends my entire
life so absolutely worthwhile doing so
find out who you truly are a person to
me and if you really are interested
meaning there's a reason that's probably
reason why they wanna be you rule number
six focus on trust
Chipotle had had a lot of troubles after
the e.coli outbreak in 2015 what went
wrong there Chipotle is basically
pioneering real food at scale there has
never been another restaurant company of
their size to do real food it's just not
even close any time you get to up to
that scale you're you're just doing a
factory food system there's no real food
in the system so they've been pioneering
and so they've they hit a speed bump but
along the way and now they're probably
the safest food restaurant in in the
world because of all the learnings that
they went through on that but on the
trust side you know Trust is the
currency of our generation if if you
break trust expect to be punished but
you don't get to choose not to
participate you you either build trust
where you go away they right so in case
of Chipotle they are doubling down on
trust it's not a in next door without
total transparency we're doubling down
on trust if we do do something wrong we
will be punished for it that's the real
world you know in the old days before
the internet before the sort of amount
of information that's out there you
could get away with a lot of stuff rule
number seven stay on your toes I live in
a small town in Colorado called Boulder
and my joke is I grew up in South Africa
during the collapse of apartheid very
very difficult time then I went to
California during the rise of the
Internet exciting but difficult time and
I was in New York City during 9/11
difficult time now I'm in this little
small town of Boulder waiting for some
serious to go down so I think those had
very big impact on me and I think the
the impact personally is constant
paranoia I guess maybe
I hate to say that not in a negative way
but it's a you just kind of you know
you're waiting for something really
intense to happen all the time so I
think that just keeps you on your toes
and and keeps you moving forward
rule number eight hire proper people
when someone comes to look for a job
with us they'll say well you're not
gonna make money they're celebrating it
what's a salary job whatever that's
stuff that's the bar then the next bar
is who am I gonna be working with and if
you're working with a players then you
pass to the next test and the final test
is is this a mission that I care about
do I really want to wake up every
morning and and and and really put my
all in and if you can have all three of
those if you can do you can be paid
properly or prayed competitively but not
necessarily pay more just competitively
if you can be surrounded by eight
players and that you have a mission that
you care about you you will have people
lining up to work for you and then that
flows to where the customers and the
other customers lining up to buy a
product or use your use your brand rule
mr9 be authentic what are you benefits
that they can find a permit you know pay
attention and really caring and growing
their online brand how do you be
authentic don't pretend something is
interesting it's not interesting don't
expect anyone else to care but if you
interested in probably actually people
will be interested so be curious and
take pictures and record what you're up
to record your thoughts you can like it
and you'll number 10 the last one before
a very special bonus clip is protect
your brother speaking of your of your
brother do you think that when people
see him from from the outside not
knowing him as well as you do that he
can come across as not normal in some
ways I think he's not his he wasn't
first and he was let's say he's first a
lion in you know when he was born for
engineering skills he wasn't first in
line for social skills but that doesn't
mean he's not a great guy and very
awesome and all that stuff but yeah I
mean I think
after a while he's always I think he's
actually gotten as weird as it sounds
I've kind of gotten better in
interacting with with with folks as he
got as he gotten older and his younger
is so focused on engineering and and
making a difference I mean you know just
a lot of so many cool things there but
it but it over as he's gotten older you
started to appreciate more the
connection a family connection to
friends connection to people now I have
a special bonus skip on how to have role
models that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that is time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one what can
you do today to be more positive number
two who are three interesting people
that you can reach out to and number
three who's the next proper hire that
you need to make in your business and if
you promise to take action after
watching this video we don't just watch
videos anymore we do something after
watching them give me a hashtag believe
down in the comments make that promise
to yourself and then get to work other
people you you look up to I think the
the two that I look up to in my way I
look for the same things you know is
kind of look back I love Winston
Churchill
yeah he's cool that guy I think is was
one of the greatest gifts to mankind and
I think Steve Jobs right yeah and I
think the thing that that makes me like
these people is that they put their
passion into their work and it's not
about the job it's not about coming to
work so about creating making a
difference in in your society and I
think that that's what what I've always
admired if my brother and with anyone
else
if you want to know Elon Musk's top five
pieces of advice check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there there's a friend of mine
who says like starting companies like
staring into the abyss and eating glass
and there's some truth to that